hello guys righteous the Ryan rightness
over here and a white test the blue good
good improv skills are coming in Annie
we're gonna check out today's ascent
Harrison Ford surprises Star Wars fans
of big news dot dot dot for charity I
have to say my favorite thing is when
celebrities do kind things for the
normies
oh me too you know I love it it's it
always makes me feel tingly inside at
night it makes me love them that much
more like that article in the magazine
that's like stars they're just like us
exactly I like doing that for people cuz
I'm a superstar I am like so popular
southern edition of a list use like
glass do they crave the list the a list
your the A+ yeah exactly
sometimes you know I'll go to people on
the street be like I know it's really
hot for you to shake my hand and that
you really appreciate this and like I
don't know who you are I'll be like
that's the way to play it humble my
friends take care take care god you're
sittin I'm a home I'm a humble blessing
either a Harrison Ford and I'm here
today with some folks from omae's to
surprise some past donors to Star Wars
force for change with a pretty big
announcement
check it out either
no I don't have to do that I'm so
excited
why are you doing so where are you right
up on it Briscoe winning in Washington
DC boy are you a big star Wars fan
absolutely few Star Wars fan yes we're
making a very exciting announcement we
are actually gonna be launching a brand
new campaign around Star Wars The Force
awakens how would you like to be one of
the first people to see the force
awakens does that sound good
give us one second picture of your
boyfriend that's maybe you can do so
much better would you fit the character
who's your character the reason we're
calling you is because we're announcing
a new campaign and this time they're
going to be two grand prize winners each
of them will get four tickets you get to
walk the red carpet go to the
after-party
you can stay up that late meet the cast
and I'll arrange to have a special
introduction to the hairy guy for you
does that sound good
[Applause]
how cool is that
incredible incredible thank you very
much for donating last time we raised
over four million dollars for great
causes and we're hoping to repeat it
this time wait what do I have to have to
donate now who's your favorite character
now you got it well done
now it's your turn join me and the rest
of the cast is supporting some
remarkable causes for your chance to
attend the red carpet premiere of Star
Wars The Force awakens click the button
or go to omae's comm slash Star Wars
standard I gotta do that
I gotta do them we mean old characters
hey nice talking to you see how much
cooler Daenerys and forges camps are
doing them
Harrison forges earned so much cred only
as if he like didn't already deserve
enough credit yeah yeah but like please
I'm speechless yes she seems like such a
down-to-earth cool fun guy even with the
earring which was weird it's really to
me I'm fired yeah but now I'm like God
good for you for an old dude but that's
the manic agent style you know he know
what I recently rewatched episode 4 he's
more handsome now when he was that in my
opinion I agree I totally agree I don't
know there's just something about it
he's just so handsome it's like the
Harrison 40 is now has so much wisdom
and experience yeah and y'all see a
little bit more like I don't give a [ __ ]
I don't give a [ __ ] yeah like it's kind
of a tough I don't give a [ __ ] attitude
love it don't mine and you could see a
sense of humor today contagious ah dude
I've seen him in interviews he has a
weird sense of humor and seeing this is
like I love seeing Harrison Ford have
fun with the fans like that
my favorite part who is your favorite
game yeah Tina starts crying I would a
trip some major balls oh yeah oh yeah I
got to figure out how to get involved in
this what is this you think you have to
donate Oh what you think you do last
thing I want to do is give away my money
jogging
I you know a lot of people get free porn
I don't settle for that I have to pay
for my porn $175 a month No Wow premium
you porn premium read to premium
punished tube calm okay maybe we should
find out what they're actually donating
to because maybe it's a cause worthy of
maybe not I'm not watching porn for
Allah all right let's see what it is
we're gonna create an awareness I just
thing you know what it donates to I
really like I've been looking for
charities and stuff how what's the
biggest you could a sold out whoa
someone donated 20 fat people donated
$20,000 what can I get
Wow what is the money go to I just need
just a general nonprofit that donates to
different charities I thought it looks
that's what it looks like with multiple
charities okay cool yeah that sounds
awesome
interesting so omae's works with
existing charities to create projects
that if people donate they get a reward
kind of like on IndieGoGo you can donate
and get a perk ah so they organized that
like appearances from the force awakens
or whatever but they work with lots of
different charities it sounds like I'm
glad you read that because I was only
pretending to read that hoping you would
absorb the information and pass it along
to me nicely I'm a really quick readers
okay I was stuck on his wise magic
Johnson young Magic Johnson about to
play b-ball and his like I started with
him he went to a benefit and people paid
to get to meet him and all that money
went to charity Oh
reading kids woman's like for pear girl
actually important for her dress short
pear guys yeah that's like four
sentences but look at all the knowledge
I have now oh yeah guys um donate to
amazed they help out with a lot of
causes you can just go to their site
I'll put a link
the description box for it apparently
this opportunity gets you the chance to
possibly win tickets and meet the cast
of Star Wars The Force awakens
I would love to participate in that what
what is not sold out currently well
there was only two things that were sold
out you can get t-shirts printed poster
limited quantity would printed film
still oh really that's 250 bucks with
the money I make that is like pennies
but all dependencies we pennies and the
lowest you can donate is $10 but that
also looks like enters you to win yeah
hundred chances but if you donate $250
that gives you 2,500 chance oh that's
smart
that's like buying a lot of lottery
tickets how many chances do you think
they're gonna be in total I don't know
what the odds are gonna be is you know
what man that it's like playing the
lottery at this point well yes but the
more money you donate the better chance
you have and also it's a win-win because
you're donating money to charity people
say the same thing about lotteries and
how they go to schools lotteries go to
some lottery money is like help out with
public education I do not know that I
think I'm just making that no my just me
make my gosh I have not heard yeah well
anyway guys I did this video to create
an awareness so sure I think they did a
really great job of making it a viral
video she's a CEO itself it's great when
I can contribute to a charity I like to
just contribute to the charity I'm not
like I want to make this money back in
something right right but it's kind of
cool to know I'll get something in
return if I don't even help out that's
pretty cool you know they could probably
auction off tickets to see the start of
the new Star Wars movie and meet the
meet the fans for profit they can oh
people would pay for it anyway so they
might as well team up with a charity and
I think that's really awesome of that
you know excuse me an idea for $500 you
can meet me for 10 minutes and the money
would go to the gym you yeah how are you
worth haha nobody else active anything
hey guys thanks for tuning in to the
channel if you're new to it subscribe
today and become a region
- rejected by whichever one you want to
go with people are arguing between the
two and Breanna white as a gaming
channel Breanna
White's gaming channel sibling rivalry
where you could watch her play games and
crack a joke here or there it's a good
time you teach dabble it's a good time
they dabble in humans really excited
Ellis drew you're just selling like
Mexican ice cream I don't have a problem
that it's Mexican ice cream it's just
they're so loud